hello and welcome to another video on
code tech and tutorials huge shout out
to my community for voting and taking
part in this little uh words how do they
work pull voice coding and i'm always uh
just kind of making little progress
updates here and there and i
don't know what to do with these vlogs
they're not i don't know if they're all
that entertaining but to other coders or
people that want to just hear thought
processes on code it might be great so i
couldn't decide if i wanted to put them
on the main channel or on a whole other
channel because they're not going to be
as edited as my normal weekly content
these vlogs are going to be like a bonus
basically and i wanted to get at least
you know around 100 votes before i
committed and i really thought that the
second channel was
a better idea like in my opinion i was i
was thinking i don't want to clutter up
my main channel it's a bunch of like
rambly code vlogs but i think we'll
they'll serve a purpose and i guess will
be better than i think
because you guys seem to agree with that
and uh i was kind of lumping the i don't
know into second channel because that
was my vote so up still
a heavy 78 on the put them on this main
channel the point of these is to not be
edited so there's almost no editing in
them but there's a lot of talking and
there's a lot of theory
and there's potentially a lot of my
mistakes and the way i'm thinking or
designing which you'll see probably
corrected later but also a big portion
of this is for people to like have
discussions below about like oh he's
doing this and that's great or he's
doing this and that's not going to work
hey why don't you try you know just
stuff like that just discussion for us
all to kind of learn and have examples
yeah here we go i guess this is the
first series of code vlogs i'll probably
do one uh per project or per iteration
of a project or something like that all
right enjoy
all right we are doing what i would call
one of the biggest rewrites of the
ancient archer game engine
version six i am considering some design
patterns to help sort out
the structure of this mainly the model
view view model pattern
and applying it
to this bad boy
so yeah i already moved everything
around it doesn't currently work because
it's a whole new structure and it's a
lot flatter
as you can see
but we're not done all right so i got a
lot of work to do and i'm going to keep
just checking in with old code boy here
so basically what we want to do here is
get a window popping up and get things
rendering again
like it used to be and then we can go
from there
all right so i've been working on the
window i got the first callback going
now we just need to see if we can pop it
up and working and resolve all the other
errors up
most of them are just going to be
straightening out headers so it won't be
too bad
okay it's been a solid 45 minutes since
i started and pretty much all i've got
is the windowing and a little more on
the callbacks i had to do some research
to make sure i was doing some of these
callbacks right so that ate up a bunch
of time
but i'm going to take a quick break and
then i'll get back to it and update you
guys shortly
alright back at it
i've been using the
pomodoro technique with 45 minutes on
and short breaks
okay checking back in pretty situational
but i think i've found a great way to
design this class without having to make
a whole bunch of setters and getters but
instinctively having them anyway
check it out this is the thought process
i don't know if this is technically
correct or the best or whatever just
something i i think will work good for
my case
so take that for what you will
uh
okay so we making options for the class
right
and all you do is you set a single
getter to get all the options
and then unapply changes but we're going
to make
this windows options a shared pointer so
that other people can get it modify it
and then hit apply changes and it'll
update everything
and apply our changes and that's it we
don't need a getter and setter for every
single one of these there's just one
all-inclusive now the downside of this
you would think is you're passing around
a lot of data but since we're using a
shared pointer we're not we're just
passing around
just just a pointer basically the data
is all remaining where it is so this
should be pretty efficient and look it's
only
30 lines of code and that's including
everything and some extra spacing
so
uh yeah i'm kind of excited about trying
out this mode and uh this design
pattern that i don't know what this
would be called exactly but
just the idea of having a
options
and then you know a get in and apply
with a shared pointer holding that data
all right
i want to get back to it i'll check in
with more updates soon
i don't know why i do that little mini
outro every time before i hit pause it's
going to get old real quick but anyway
the point is we can now pretty much
delete all of these
and have them all go at once when we do
and apply changes
with the new options so that'll be kind
of cool huh
all right
that's the plan
and we'll see how many lines of code
that is
well for today i've pretty much gotten
up to uh
starting to get the graphics all loaded
up
so yeah window and graphics we'll
probably come back at it again tomorrow
[Music]
you